(drum beat)
- [Announcer] Ladies and
gentlemen, Whitney Cummings.
(crowd applause)
(drum beat music)
- A lot's goin' on in the past year.
I don't know if you noticed,
but people started caring
about sexual harassment all of a sudden.
I want you guys to know, I get it.
Of course you want to touch women.
They're impossible to resist.
I relate to your frustration because
sometimes I will see a
service dog at the airport.
(crowd laughs)
'cause I'm gonna pet that fucking dog.
I mean it's a dog and
it obviously wants it.
With that adorable, little butt.
I can see its butthole.
If that's not asking for
it, I don't know what is.
(drum beat music)
Could you come forward a fucking inch?
- [Audience Member] Woooooo!
I have a girlfriend, she
carries a taser that looks
like a tube of lipstick.
I argue, the best weapon
against an attacker
just regular red lipstick.
Put it in your back pocket.
Anytime a guy is hovering,
creeping around just take it out
and just start putting it on.
Be like ah, ah, ah, ah.
(crowd laughs)
Is that what you want?
(drum beat music)